bonjour merci beaucoup cécile kuperman
d'être avec nous ce matin en direct sur
rt françon françois pupponi ne saurait
tarder on est en train de se connecter
avec lui hier le conseil constitutionnel
s'est prononcé en faveur du maintien de
ce scrutin de dimanche alors que les
indépendantistes eux réclament son
report ils menacent de ne pas y
participer
quel est quelle est votre réaction
mais je crois qu'on on attaque ce
référendum en étant quasiment déjà dans
une impasse puisque nous avons une
partie des protagonistes y compris
depuis
1988 vous le rappeler qu'ils ne se
retrouvent pas dans cette date qui a
initialement il ya maintenant d'un nom
d'ailleurs les douars philippe alors
promis un premier ministre avait dit
qu'elle ne tiendrait pas à cette période
d'abord ya à proximité de l'élection
présidentielle et puis depuis
effectivement vient de se rajouter en
nouvelle calédonie comme malheureusement
partout sur la planète les conséquences
de cette pandémie et de la difficulté
notamment en nouvelle calédonie à pois
organiser la campagne électorale et donc
faire en sorte que le référendum puisse
se tenir de manière sincère c'est à dire
après un véritable débat démocratique
sur l'île avec les différents habitants
françois pupponi merci beaucoup de nous
avoir rejoints pour ce débat on parlait
de ce maintien donc de ce référendum
dimanche est ce que le choix de la date
est judicieux selon vous
écouter il est at elle est fixé depuis
longtemps matters le taux d'incidence au
niveau social du terme étaient dix à
cinquante donc au niveau sanitaire on
peut le faire le con sexuelle a confirmé
et je pense qu'il est toujours très
compliqué d'arrêter un processus
démocratique qui est candidate depuis
longtemps puisque c'est le troisième
référendum ça long processus qui a été
mis en place et dont je pense que les
conditions maintenant se réunit pour que
en tout cas le référendum ait lieu le
conseil que celle là confirmer donc
effectivement ce référendum peut et va
avoir lieu alors on va regarder les les
résultats des deux premiers tours pour
bien comprendre ce dont on parle 56 7%
contre 43,3 le 4 novembre 2018 53,3
contre 46 7 ans en 2020 on le voit le
vote indépendantiste a progressé là ce
ne serait pas le cas puisque à priori
dont ils ont décidé de le boycotter mais
un report aurait pu faire basculer en
faveur de l'indépendance selon vous
cécile kuperman c'était le risque
non quoi d'abord je pense que c'est vous
savez très compliqué d'annoncer des
résultats d'une élection qu'elle ait pu
se tenir donc je
m'amuserais pas à faire quelques
hypothèses qui pourraient douteuses je
crois qu'effectivement on va de toute
façon être dans une véritable difficulté
sur l'île à l'issue du maintien de ce
référendum c'est que comme dîner de le
dire et ça nous le savons depuis
maintenant quelques semaines
celles et ceux qui portent la question
d'indépendance en tout cas ont décidé de
ne pas fournir leurs marques north
matériel pardo électorale et ben on va
donc inévitablement
faire qui lui ouvre un résultat qui
n'est peut-être pas à l'image de ce que
pense la police et la population sur sur
place et qu'il y aura de toutes les
façons malheureusement aurait janvier
d'ailleurs de dire au lendemain du
référendum
des mesures des discussions à poursuivre
et à continuer parce que l'objectif
premier pour la nouvelle calédonie et
surtout que la situation sur l'île
demeure vivable et acceptable pour
chacune et chacun est qu'il n'y ait pas
de nouveaux événements
de deux expressions de colère qui
viendrait à mettre en difficulté je
crois chacune et chacun quelle que soit
d'ailleurs son positionnement par
rapport aux huiles ou non du référendum
de dimanche moi j'entends ce qui a été
dit par an le conseil d'état ce que
vient de rappeler monsieur pony sur le
taux d'incidence qui est réel et la
question n'est surtout pas de remettre
en question mais l'auteur d'une campagne
ne se faisait pas simplement la semaine
qui précède l'élection et nous savons
que depuis quand même plusieurs mois à
lille a été fortement frappés par cette
pandémie françois pupponi quelle est la
légitimité de cette consultation si les
premiers concernés à savoir les
indépendantistes au n'y prennent pas
part
c'est vrai que ça va bien entendu
fossier résultats dès lors qu une partie
d'une partie importante de l'électorat
qui décide de ne pas participer le
résultat ne sera pas du tout
effectivement le même ça sera mon
troisième référendum c'est a quand même
du sens et de toutes les manières il
faut qu'on le savait mais conserver même
avant que les indépendantistes décide d
pas participé partie d'entre eux qu'il
faudra après le référendum continue à
réfléchir à l'avenir calédonie le
référendum le troisième référendum
n'était pas la fin c'est la fin d'un
processus on savait très bien qu'il
fallait dès le lendemain et fléchir à
l'évolution y compris institutionnelle
en hôtellerie parce que de toutes les
manières tout avait été pensé en
imaginant peut-être qu'il y aurait un
vote favorable indépendante qui sonnera
de toutes les manières que les parties
continuent à travailler ensemble à
discuter pour imaginer l'avenir en
nouvelle calédonie c'est la fin d'un
processus mais c'est ce processus qui va
s'arrêter avec 6 troisième référendum va
être le début d'un nouveau
moyen de nouveaux processus qui
permettra d'imaginer l'avenir de
mécanique le gouvernement a donc décidé
un coup de coude de maintenir cette date
12 décembre il n'a pas voulu non plus
prendre position gouvernement sébastien
lecornu a été interpellé hier à
l'assemblée nationale par la droite sur
cette question vous voyez la réponse du
ministre d outre-mer
à nouméa le 5 mai 2018 vingt ans jour
pour jour après la signature de ces
accords le président de la république
dans le théâtre de l'île a marqué sa
préférence il l'a fait droit dans les
yeux devant les loyalistes les militants
du nom il l'a fait aussi devant les
indépendantistes et les militants du oui
vous pourrez répété à l'envi que ce
gouvernement n'a rien fait sur ce
dossier c'est faux quel est votre votre
avis sur cette question c'est celle qu
karman est ce que le gouvernement aurait
dû faire campagne en tout cas pour une
nouvelle calédonie française
écoutez moi je ne suis pas conseillère
politique du gouvernement donc je crois
que le gouvernement assume ses choix ils
disent qu'ils à ce qu'il souhaite dire
ce qu'ils en tout cas surprenant
peut-être c'est que effectivement quand
il y à un référendum en tout cas il y a
une position des différents
ministres du camp du premier ministre
laquelle on peut être d'accord ou pas
donc je bon je crois là qu'on est sur un
type de référendums particulier d'abord
parce que le concerne effective
uniquement la nouvelle calédonie parce
qu'il pose la question finale du devenir
des ghettos la population et donc du
rapport à la france
qu'on peut avoir effectivement cette
interrogation sur finalement son
gouvernement en difficulté quand à dire
s'il soutiendrait le oui ou le non et en
même temps ce que l'on veut réellement
respecter le droit des peuples à
l'autodétermination est toujours très
compliqué que chacun depuis paris
intercède dans ces débats qui demeure ce
avant tout de la nouvelle calédonie
françois pupponi quel est votre avis
mais est ce que le gouvernement a dû
marquer sa position non serre on est
dans un processus qui parle de la
dépendance et je pense que si
effectivement le boulava mandat public
avait pris des positions régulier r
forte pour que la nouvelle crèche
française on aurait reproché au
gouvernement en particulier un prodige
de dire mais voilà vous mettez toutes
vos pouvoirs tout vaut tous vos moyens
pour justement essayer d'influencer sur
le vote là c'est je pense très
respectueux le président 2018 l'a dit
pendant plus qu'à 10 en disant qu'il
souhaitait que bien entendu le mc alger
reste française et ensuite il a dit il a
laissé comme le gouvernement le
processus se dérouler sans influencer le
rôle qu'a voulu c'est le gouvernement
c'est uniquement d'organiser dans des
bonnes conditions ces trois
consultations il jappe est on est dans
un processus qui est quand même très
particulier qui est qu une partie de la
france décide de quitter les girondins
nationale et de retrouver l'indépendance
la semaine dernière le ministre le corps
nu à juste titre parle aussi d'un sujet
qui parle d'autonomie en martinique et
en guadeloupe il y a aussi des droits on
dit qu'à sion forte sur la corse en
termes d'autonomie on revient qui est un
processus qui est engagée par rapport à
un certain nombre de régions ou de
départements d'outre-mer française de
régions françaises comme la corse et je
pense que le gouvernement a abordé ces
questions là de la meilleure des
manières en tout cas pas l'ol fait les
dolly c'était des déroutes de laisser le
processus s'est déroulé sans influencer
fortement le vote des électeurs à rien 7
oui je vous en prie ccnucc arman un
peut-être simplement parce que je
j'entends un ce qui a été dit je veux
quand même redire ce que je disais
initialement oui le gouvernement
poursuit l'organisation du processus
mais je crois qu'au delà de la question
d'ailleurs de la crise sanitaire le
premier désaccord et notamment avec les
indépendantistes et sur l'organisation
et la date du 12 décembre 2021 et je
veux redire parce que en octobre 2019 ce
n'était pas les engagements qui avaient
été pris par le gouvernement de tenir
un référendum rentrée layton et le
printemps précédent l'élection
présidentielle je crois qu'il ya aussi
ça qu'il faut intégrer dans dans la
réflexion dans la difficulté aujourd'hui
qu'ils aient vécu la course à
participer au scrutin c'est la crise de
confiance que vous soulevez justement
qui est invoquée par par les
indépendantistes d'ailleurs je crois
qu'il joue bien évidemment est impacté
comme tout aujourd'hui pas un délit mais
il n'ya pas que la pandémie qui rend
cette situation délicate et en tout cas
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui une grande
partie des indépendantistes
ne participe à bharti s'il faut pas
pardo au processus électoral dimanche et
d'ailleurs la cour constitutionnelle n'a
pas tenu compte non plus de ce qu'on
appelle le fameux deuil kanak qui a été
invoqué pour ce report c'est une
question de culture salueront longtemps
voyez d'ailleurs les réactions des
indépendantistes à l'époque où il ya eu
cette crise de confiance et la réaction
des loyalistes sur place
jusqu'à quand la france pense t-elle
pouvoir bâtir un avenir institutionnel
durable pour la nouvelle calédonie en
s'asseyant sciemment sur la culture du
peuple kanak en feignant ostensiblement
d'ignorer la place qu'ils occupent les
cérémonies du deuil et le respect qu'on
doit aux morts en piétinant les
sentiments la sensibilité la dignité
humaine de tout un peuple qu'on dit
surtout c'est qu'il faut aller voter
c'est la troisième consultation de
l'accord de nouméa c'est à l'issue de
cette consultation qu'on va pouvoir
passer à autre chose et il faut que les
calédoniens malgré les modernes qui ont
été lancées par les uns les autres
aillent voter
né à ce que le résultat de ce vote soit
significatif politiquement le fait est
qu'ils en demandent est ce troisième
référendum que l'état organisé qu'il
aura lieu dimanche prochain que cette
troisième consultation de l'accord de
nouméa sera passé et donc l'accord
nominera de l'union sera fini il est
prévu à l'issue un poids de dans
l'éventualité de trois noms successifs
qu'on se retrouve sur la table pour
envisager la situation ainsi créée c'est
comme ça que c'est écrit et c'est ce qui
se passera bien françois pupponi
réaction à cette identité kanak qui est
peut-être mal comprises à paris et et
qu'est ce que ça révèle ce que ce qu'on
vient d'entendre il ya un vrai clivage
aussi chez les calédoniens
il est évident que vendus dans un
processus d'indépendance c'est à dire
qu'à un moment il ya une partie du
territoire national en nouvelle
calédonie où effectivement il ya eu des
tirs monnaies sur les accords de
l'ouvert c'est qu'il ya eu aussi des
drames les vies des morts il ya eu des
situations qui était plus acceptable et
si un moment la france a accepté de se
mettre dans un processus d'éventuels
indépendance c'est qu'on voit bien qu'il
y a une relation que l'on doit être que
nous à mettre en place différemment avec
la nouvelle gamme dédiée au cas présent
mais ça peut être aussi avec nos anti
cpe avec un homme deux de nos
territoires bien entendu qu'il fallait
que les choses changent car là on est
dans un processus démocratique
c'est le troisième référendum les deux
premiers ont donné naissance à une
courte majorité d'ailleurs c'est donc un
sujet qui voit bien que qui démontre
bien que la situation en nouvelle
qu'elle nie et qui lie avec un clivage
profond entre ceux qui veulent
effectivement se séparer de la france et
les autres mais comme c'est évident le
reportage le processus va aller à son
terme le 13 décembre et ensuite il
faudra imaginer si on considère que dans
les circonstances le oui l'emportera
pour la troisième fois il faudra quand
même imaginer la suite et mails si bien
entendu la nouvelle galles du reste
française il va falloir organiser des
nouvelles relations entre paris et
et la nouvelle calédonie pour faire en
sorte qu'on ne soit plus dans ce
sentiment de
ressenti de malaise entre s'étalant
jusqu'à la manière il est possible et
françois pupponi ces discussions que
l'on vous parle et elles ne seront pas
sereine si les indépendantistes tony
participé y aura forcément
si aussi plus que je te veux le dire et
le communiqué des indépendantistes c'est
une manière de mettre en place des
relations qui tienne compte beaucoup
plus que 7 est le cas dans le passé de
la manière dont justement ce peuple ce
peuple qu'elle vient ressent les choses
et souvent dans ces territoires ce qui
n'est pas acceptée c'est la manière dont
paris les considère donc il faudra
effectivement que l'on mette en place
des nouvelles relations ou la prise en
compte de la spécificité du peuple kanak
soit est mieux prise en compte c'est une
revendication qui est historique
légitime effectivement il faudra changer
de type de relation on va on va parler à
présent des réactions à droite et à
gauche un ces derniers jours on en a
entendu beaucoup à droite les le
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
eric zemmour a même publié une vidéo
hier soir eric ciotti également des
républicains a réagi regardez
manche les néo-calédoniens doivent dire
non indépendance je refuse d'offrir aux
indépendantistes la neutralité de l'état
français comme l'a fait macron plus que
jamais la nouvelle calédonie c'est la
france le système de discrimination
électoral inique qui a été institué en
nouvelle calédonie exclu des dizaines de
milliers de citoyens français du droit
de vote soit près de 18 % du corps
électoral
mais ce système a été validé par la cod
h qui s'émeut du temps de travail de nos
militaires mais valide des infractions
aussi flagrante au principe le plus
fondamental de la démocratie cécile du
kerman 7 ce dégel du corps électoral
prenais part par eric zemmour je
rappelle que c'est une liste électorale
spéciale qui permet de s'exprimer pour
ce référendum et elle a été restreinte
par plusieurs critères lors des accords
de nouméa est ce qu il a raison et eric
zemmour allemand en dénonçant le fait
qu'ils aient beaucoup d'électeurs mis de
côté
je crois que nous fait vous ne faites
pas offenserait me demandant de valider
les propos d'eric zemmour avec lui
quelques jours rien à voir c'est pas le
je crois qu'à question de la
constitution effectivement tout cas de
la liste électorale
surprise individus comme celui-ci
s'immisce dans ce débat sur la nouvelle
calédonie mais enfin bon tout est
possible justement ça me renvoie
d'ailleurs à la pertinence de
l'organisation d'un référendum au plein
aucun début de campagne présidentielle
et je crois qu'on a tout ça il faut être
très prudent les uns comme les autres
pour ne pas récupérer utiliser ce qui va
se passer aux nouvelles kalidou à des
fins finalement très parisienne voilà la
liste électorale ait établi ça a été un
processus compliqué un point d équilibre
a été a été trouvé et de toutes les
façons ils seront en boucle sur ce que
nous sommes dit dès lors que le
référendum était fermée dimanche il
s'appuiera s'appuiera sur ceux ci - je
joue qu'à très attentif à ce qui se
passera après la nouvelle calédonie est
déjà aujourd'hui avec
de statut particulier dans son
organisation il faut aller encore plus
loin un pic à la question de l'autonomie
et de la construction à partir de là
mais vallecano comment autour de la
problématique du droit coutumier qui a
qui a toute son importance et déjà sa
place dans l'organisation pour aupic à
faire en sorte le sentiment qui n'est
plus dingue on état colonial mais un
partenariat entre ont eu la nouvelle
calédonie et et la france et la
république soit dans un respect ciment
des ddd tout l'histoire et
fonctionnement de chacun de ces
territoires je vois dubitatif françois
pupponi je vais vous laisser réagi mais
comme il nous reste très peu de temps je
voudrais vous passez vous parler du
passé colonial c'est le cri karman
ecoutez jean luc mélenchon et et
philippe poutou deux candidats à
l'élection présidentielle qui ont aussi
parlé de la nouvelle calédonie regarder
en refusant d'entendre la demande de
report du référendum emmanuel macron
prend le risque de recréer les
conditions du conflit actuellement
apaisé solidarité avec les luttes du
peuple kanak contre le colonialisme
français et pour leurs droits à
l'autonomie étant donné la gravité de la
crise sanitaire actuelle soutient
l'exigence de reporter le référendum sur
l'avenir de la kanaky nouvelle calédonie
françois pupponi c'est devenir un enjeu
de la présidentielle
quelque part oui mais parce que de voir
se situe à quelques semaines de
l'élection présidentielle
et puis c'est on voit bien avec le débat
avec eux et allument zemmour et les
saucisses et une choriste et de
conception de la france une certaine
conception de l'état central avec une
partie de ces territoires de la manière
dont on doit considérer respecter ces
territoires prendre en contre leur
histoire leur culture est donc bien
entendu que c'est une certaine image de
la france qui doit se dessiner et que à
l'occasion de l'élection présidentielle
on voit bien que les candidats vont
chacun exprimé leurs positions certains
considèrent que la france doit continuer
à être nouvelle calédonie et que l'on
boit pas trop s'occuper de ce que
pensent les habitants historiques la
kanaky tant d'autres qui disent au
contraire on doit absolument tenir
compte de ce qu'ils pensent et je pense
que effectivement on sera dans
l'obligation dans notre pays des changer
d'attitude vis-à-vis d'un sérum de
territoire on devra plus prendre en
compte l'histoire de ces peuples qui
vivent sur cette terre qui sont devenus
dans des conditions diverses et variées
qui ont les cas français mais qu'on peut
plus considérer comme on est oublié
complètement qu'ils sont et d'où ils
viennent et un enjeu majeur aussi du du
maintien de la nouvelle calédonie en
france c'est évidemment sa situation
dans la zone pacifique très stratégique
après la claque des sous marins
notamment ccnucc herman düne ouest louis
inévitablement là on rentre on questions
géopolitiques qui est qui a toujours été
un l'enjeu
de sa présence y compris sur tous les
océans et tous les continents
et on voit bien outils que ce juste
derrière et peut-être que ce n'est pas
suffisamment dit d'ailleurs suffisamment
expliqué c'est que se passe-t-il demain
d'antan dans cette zone de la planète
mais je ne crois que cela va au delà
d'ailleurs de la question d'indépendance
d'ailleurs puisque le vois très bien
mais que son réseau social et l'oni la
question des soins que vous écoutiez
mais au-delà de ça dont l'influencé de
la place la france pour construire et
pour porter aussi les ces philosophies
universaliste et aujourd'hui en retrait
en séculaire banal pardon j'aimerais
bien que françois pupponi répondent
aussi et il nous reste vraiment 30
secondes françois pupponi la la zone
pacifique
stratégique évidemment pour la france il
faut absolument maintenir la nouvelle
calédonie française renforcée peut-être
une présence militaire sur place
c'est toute façon la situation nouvelle
qualif c'est que la france a intérêt à
rester localement quelle honte sur place
c'est le pacifique c'est indispensable
la chine surveille de près ce référendum
par le but bien entendu bien entendu que
toulon le cholet et que si la dépendance
avait été votée considère donc taper les
trois à référendum il ya eu et sera pas
d'autres puissances très forte aurait eu
intérêt à vous dire
merci beaucoup pardonnez-moi cécile
cukierman de vous avoir coupé la parole
merci beaucoup c'était très intéressant
merci pour ce débat ce matin en direct
sur rt france